their radicalism is not only bleeding
into culture but also into governance
and you as a free citizen in this
country this is where you're going to be
able to fight back if you vote in the
right people so we can get rid of these
clowns so AOC who is a congresswoman she
is a complete uh she is what she is okay
and I will give her credit in that she
has somehow become a media uh darling
right she may be an idiot she may have
no qualifications to do this but she is
someone that people pay attention to I
believe at this point she is in her
complete uh a complete violation of her
oath of office as most Democrats are at
this point I don't know that anything
can be done about that but these people
they swear to defend the Constitution of
the United States and yet the Democrats
spend most of their time trying to shred
the Constitution much like Nancy Pelosi
remember when she Shred the papers
behind Donald Trump after that State of
the Union that's what they mostly do
most of what the Dem Democrats talk
about is how to destroy the Constitution
uh here's AOC
I personally believe
that this is a position that is in any
way controversial to anyone the degree
and extent of misconduct uh that
Clarence Thomas Alone
um in addition to several of his
colleagues have participated and engaged
in is the legitimate foundationally
delegitimizing to the Supreme Court and
it is our responsibility our
constitutional duty to Reign them in
so nothing she said there has any
meaning whatsoever notice she didn't get
into any of the legal arguments that
Clarence Thomas made or Samuel Alito
made or anyone else made it's just her
feelings about this she's not happy with
his decisions and she should impeach him
or she should pack the court so that the
court can no longer function so the
court will act as a branch of the
legislative a branch you understand that
uh so she she is just a complete buffoon
but it's sort but the media loves it the
media loves an assault on all of the
systems the media loves watching our
institutions burn and the Democrats love
watching the institutions burn because
without a system of checks and balances
if we didn't have a judicial branch that
could look at what the legislative
branch is doing and an executive branch
that could sign things into laws and
that these things could all fight it out
and argue over each other if we if we
could actually destroy that if AOC could
do what she wants impeach judges who
don't make decisions the way she wants
them to or pack courts so that the
branch itself cannot operate as an
independent as an independent branch of
government but just as sort of this like
secondary legislative branch then what
would happen well you'd have one power
one power that would control everything
that's all progressives want you have to
forget the gender nonsense and critical
race Theory and all of those things
they're important to talk about they're
important to identify but what does it
all lead to
It All Leads to their power more and
more power for them